[Musique]
il s'est fait coincer par la
géante côté car à monsieur n'est pas une
monsieur commissaire de police
pourriture communiste dit au préfet que
j'avais un hélico dans dix minutes ils
ont la butte marthonie veut un hélico
dans les dix minutes sinon il la butte
il dit que vous bluffez petite fille que
j'ai plus de jeunes où il dit qu'il a
plus de jeunes où il dit qu'il voit pas
le rapport
vous êtes adele doré non je suis le pas
puis j'attends ma soeur
dessin chiffres on peut se tutoyer sympa
t'es lourd mais j'ai quand même enfin
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez le coeur bien
accroché parce que c'est une véritable
boucherie à l'intérieur qu'est-ce qui
les connaît qu'est-ce qui connaît aux
femmes
rick hunter je sais pas si m
au nom aussi s'ils prônent assume covini
vous voulez un whisky ou juste un doigt
vous départ whisky d'abord dans son la
cale
c'est bien
les ai tous cas moi
[Musique]
oh oui
dansons la qualité
tant pis y est de produire à tout le
monde pour moi
[Musique]
à ses côtés